On sait très bien que le plus important c'est pas le physique,
Mais c'est ce qu'il y a dans la tête.
Par exemple moi, j'me sens vraiment mal,
Quand je rencontre une personne où je sais pas si c'est une fille ou un garçon.
Ces gens là, ils le savent !
On a du leur dire déjà dix mille fois !
Alors pourquoi ils font pas un petit effort en mettant un signe distinctif ?
On dirait que ça les fait kiffer de jouer à être parfaitement entre les deux !
"Bah j'suis désolé mais c'est normal que tout le monde te prenne pour un mec !
T'as vu comment tu t'habilles ?"
"Euuuhh ... bah j'suis vraiment un mec en fait"
"Ah ouais c'est p't'être pour ça en fait ..."
En fait il faut assumer son physique,
Parce que les gens qui ont des complexes ça se voit direct !
Quand ils assument pas une partie de leur corps ou leur physique,
Tu le grilles tout de suite ! Et c'est encore plus ridicule !
*rire soufflé*
"Excuse-moi, j'suis désolé mais, qu'est-ce que t'arrête pas de faire là ?
T'es complexé de ton sourire ou ... ?"
"Ah non pas du tout, c'est juste que je pue de la gueule !"
C'est comme les meufs qui veulent pas qu'on regarde leurs fesses parce qu'elles les trouvent trop grosses !
Elles font tout pour le cacher mais ... C'est grillé à dix mille kilomètres !
Du coup on le voit encore plus quoi :
(Prof) : Juliette !
Au tableau !
(Juliette) : Oui !
Alors ...
Alors euh racine ... alors ...
Racine carrée de 8 =
Après y'a aussi l'inverse des mecs qui sont complexés
C'est ceux qui en font des tonnes !
Par exemple les mecs qui ont un tatouage !
On dirait qu'ils font absolument tout pour le montrer au maximum !
"Ouais."
"Mmmh"
"Ouais"
"Mouais"
"Ah bah clairement, clairement clairement."
"Après si tu veux ça ..."
"C'est la base du bouddhisme !"
Ce qui m'énerve le plus chez les mecs qui ont un tatouage,
C'est qu'on dirait qu'ils doivent toujours le justifier par une raison mystique,
Une histoire super complexe :
"Bah ça correspond à un moment de ma vie où j'étais complètement en bad."
"Du coup je suis parti en Inde avec mes potes en mobylette,"
"Pour construire une école de rétro-gaming"
"Pour les enfants malades."
"Et il fallait que je le fasse !"
"Si tu veux c'était nécessaire j'en avais besoin,"
"C'est comme si Dieu m'avait demandé de le faire en fait."
"Ca veut dire "Que Dieu te garde"."
"Ah, ok."
"Moi en fait je parle couramment le langage hindi,"
"Et j'crois que ça veut pas du tout dire ça."
"Ah bon ?"
"Ca veut dire quoi alors ?"
"Bah ça veut dire euh ..."
"Qui veut du fromage ?"
"Oh putain ils se sont foutus de ma gueule !"
Mais les mecs qui portent des tatouages,
C'est le genre de mecs qui portent des chapeaux.
Moi j'aimerais bien porter un chapeau mais ...
C'est pas du tout mon style, tu vois, ça me va pas.
Mais dès que je mets un chapeau
Les gens qui me trouvent moche avec
pour pas me vexer ils me disent :
"Nan j'sais pas t'as ...
T'as pas une tête à chapeaux toi."
Ça voudrais dire qu'il y a des mecs qui naturellement,
Ont une tête à chapeaux ?
Genre ils sont nés comme ça !
"Poussez !"
*soufflements brefs et réguliers*
"Voilàà"
"Alors ? C'est une fille ou un garçon ?
"Hmmmmm"
"Ça j'en sais rien du tout, mais c'que je peux vous dire"
"C'est qu'il a une putain"
"De tête à chapeaux !"
"Ah c'est génial !"
"Regardez:"
"C'est magnifique."
Y'a des gens qui disent "tête à lunettes" aussi.
Mais c'est tout !
Pour autre chose ça se dit pas quoi.
Y'a jamais un mec qui dit :
"Ça m'va pas, j'ai pas une tête à pull !"
Moi j'ai p't'être une tête à coussins ?
"Bonsoir !"
C'est comme les mecs qui portent des
Des maillots de foot,
mais dans la rue !
Ça ça m'énerve aussi ça.
"Ça va les gars ?"
"Ça va mec ?"
"Ca va ou quoi ?"
Les maillots de foot,
C'est fait pour jouer au foot sur un terrain !
J'sais pas les fans de natation,
Ils se promènent pas dans la rue comme ça :
"Ça va les gars ?"
"Ça va mec ? Tranquille ?"
"Ça va ou quoi ?"
Moi par exemple je suis blanc,
Dans ma famille y'a pas beaucoup de noirs.
Bon !
Y'en a même zéro en fait !
Et c'est vrai que je suis pas toujours à l'aise pour parler des origines.
Par exemple quand je rencontre un renoi ou un métis,
J'ose jamais lui demander d'où il vient parce que ...
J'ai toujours peur qu'il me prenne pour un énorme raciste.
"Et toi tu viens d'où en fait ?"
"J'ai pas l'air français pour toi ??"
"Ah sisi !"
" 'Fin nan nan mais euh c'est juste que euh"
"C'est juste que t'as un physique un peu euh ..."
"Tropical !"
"Mais c'est des clichés d'merde ça !"
"C'est super cliché t'es ouf !"
"Ah excuse moi ouais nan euh"
"Mais t'as une vision du Moyen-Âge mec !"
"Ouais j'avoue ouais"
" "Ouais j'avoue mouais !" "
" 'Tain mais c'est super raciste c'que tu viens de dire !"
Tu m'fous l'seum ..."
(chuchote) "Super raciste ..."
"J'rigole j'suis congolais !"
*rigolent*
"T'inquiètes négro euh ..."